foreign
[Music]
now Maggie on the other hand is one bad
but sadly her own agenda thinks
the batter is the puppy that
replaced her so Bella looked at me like
I want to call Pikachu so I was like I'm
gonna get her a cupcake I'm so here for
that right so Jenna said which I did but
then I thought wouldn't it be cute if I
acted all confused and tilted my head
like huh oh my God man she'll got to
suck to compete with that no it's fine
fell as young and cute and fun so of
course Jenna loves him more than me
right now and I get that cool anyways I
was thinking if you guys were free later
what I really don't get is why Jenna
thinks it's so adorable when she spins
around in circles like I can do that in
my sleep but you know what it's totally
fine it's fine okay you know what it
doesn't get to me so much anymore I'm
fine I'm not jealous or worried or angry
or depressed or confused or fuming or
unhinged at all yeah you seem totally
fine and now that Jenna's spending so
much time with Bella it's given me a
chance to do a little self-care like
I've been going into the digging I
really like the feeling of the soil
under my nails I'm just like out in the
fresh air again I'm just really
connecting to the land no I'm learning I
love digging I love digging I love it
thank you
what what's happening hi there uh big
dogs I'm trying to get home I know which
way that is oh great
oh no that can't be right
I'm lost you're a stray man you can do
anything you want this beer doesn't
taste good but I like how it's making me
feel have you ever humped anything
before I recently this couch
that's sex in my life and she dirty too
no well I I can tell looks like she
hasn't been washed in years I'll see you
later baby it was nice to meet you I
really should find my way back home we
could help
we're completely lost and my little
puppy paw pads are really hurting right
now this could be a lot worse how could
this get worse huh how could it get
worse
hold on Buddy
oh wow your balls look huge from this
angle thank you but holy
never seen
some
I'm starving how many of these should we
eat all of them give me a sec whoa you
look different you look different too
how so is it my human hands hold up
the cops cool kind what do we do calm
down I got this hello officer none of us
shut the up
foreign
[Music]